قصف الام الطارات الحربيه في هذه
المنطقه على ما يبدو احد المنازل تم
استهدافها الان ونحن بينما نقوم بعمليه
تغطيه كما تشاهدون في
الصوره تدمير
واسع بفضل الله يعني
نجونا جراء هذا القصف الذي تم في وسط
محافظه خان يونس حيث تم تدمير هذا على ما
يبدو منزل احد المنازل بصاروخ من قبل
طارات الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي تحلق في
اجواء هذه المنطقه بشكل مكثف الى جانب
طائرات الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه يعني دخان
ابيض
متصاعد نتيجه هذا
القصف
العنيف والكبير في وسط محافظه خانيونس
تحديدا في
شارع البحر او شارع الشيخ احمد ياسين كما
يطلق
عليه سيارات الدفاع
المدني تحركت في هذه
المنطقه لكن المنطقه مخلاه
تماما لا يتواجد فيها مواطنين قد يكون تم
استهداف منزل كما تش في الصوره اعمل
الدخان تتصاعد حتى هذه اللحظه جراء هذه
الغاره العنيفه والشديده التي نفذتها
طائره
الاحتلال القصف
مستمر المدفعي والصاروخي
الجوي اطلاق النار مستمر ولا يتوقف في هذه
المنطقه ابدا في وسط محافظه خانيونس
يعني كما شاهدتم قبل قليل العمليه
العسكريه مستمره في وسط محافظه خان يونس
القذائف تساقط بين الحين والاخر ايضا
صواريخ الاحتلال طائرات الارهابيه تطلق
بينن والخر تستهدف منازل المواطنين مع هذا
القصف الشديد المواطنون خاصه في الاجزاء
الغربيه من وسط المحافظه يحاولون البحث عن
اماكن امنه وملذات امنه في ظل استمرار
العمليه العسكريه في وسط محافظه خان يونس
مع كل صاروخ هناك تدمير للبنيه التحتيه
تدمير نازل المواطنين وايضا ارتقاء شهداء
واصابات لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر
خان يونس جنوب قطاع عزه